en plus la plupart des collectivités se
sont vu retirer leur capacité à lever
l'impôt et en fixer son assiette les
collectivités sont de plus en plus
dépendante de l'état alors je fais une
proposition immédiate d'abord je rendrai
en 15 ans les 15 milliards d'euros
collectivités pris sous le mandat
hollande et j'indique serait la dgf sur
l'inflation puis ensemble nous
retravaillerons à une dgf adaptée aux
spécificités de chaque collectivité la
législation la législature celle qui
démarrera la devra démarrer par un pacte
financier vous n'êtes vous donnant de la
lisibilité sur les cinq ans qui viennent
j'engagerai également une grande réforme
de la fiscalité pour une fiscalité plus
juste plus redistributive en redonnant
aux collectivités les moyens de prélever
l'impôt et de mettre en oeuvre les
politiques décider ensemble avec les
habitants je veux des métropolites et la
france je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises
au cours de cette campagne car je
considère qu'il ya trop de pouvoirs
concentrés dans les grandes métropoles
trop de concurrence entre les grandes
métropoles et les autres collectivités
et trop de moyens qui arrivent dans ces
grandes métropoles dans ces grandes
villes et les miettes laissées aux
petites communes et aux villages qui se
trouvent aux abords c'est d'ailleurs la
théorie du ruissellement mise en oeuvre
par le candidat macron on donne tout aux
gros et les miettes au petit c'est pour
ça que moi je propose le roux celle m'en
sers donner des moyens aux petits aux
petites communes et ça profitera à tout
le monde
[Musique]